Speaker 1: Let's talk a little bit about William
Barr.
William Barr was the attorney general at the
end of Donald Trump's failed presidential
term, and William Barr has basically turned
on Trump, but would probably still vote for
him over a Democrat.
I know.
Think think that through.
But William Barr has now said, listen, all
of this stuff about privilege doesn't make
sense.
Trump having documents at a country club doesn't
make sense.
None of it makes sense.
And now it does appear as though Trump has
fully turned on William Barr as well, sort
of a deranged open mic night feel at Bedminster
over the weekend.
That's one of Donald Trump's golf clubs.
And in what is just an absolutely terrible,
terrible attempt at stand up comedy, Trump
went after Bill Barr basically by calling
him fat, saying all he wanted to do was check
this out.
And I apologize for the poor audio quality.
Speaker 2: I have a the steps that we have
these tweets, stupid people, attorney generals
that don't know how to do in general.
Bill Barr, only one who is a.
And so we have a whole range of school of
thought.
Know what he was going to tell you about the
rules?
Speaker 1: Yeah.
What's crazier?
The things that Trump says, like my attorney
general was fat, even though, by the way,
Trump doesn't exactly look like he's missed
too many meals or the fact that the cult members
laugh as if this stuff were funny, as if this
stuff were fine.
Both are kind of weird.
Another clip.
This also, I believe this is also from Bedminster,
but in a different room or something here.
Trump is already suggesting that Sarah Huckabee
Sanders was running for governor of Arkansas.
And yes, she's the daughter of former Arkansas
Governor Mike Huckabee.
Trump already is floating that Sarah Huckabee
Sanders is going to have the election stolen
from her due to this ubiquitous and ever present
fraud.
Speaker 2: Born of Trump tied that right mind.
And I said, I love this guy, I love this guy.
But Mike has been a friend of mine from the
beginning and his daughter, as you know.
And I do.
I give Janet the credit.
I give the credit.
But they're both here, by the way, do incredible
people.
But his daughter is just an exceptional person.
Yeah, an exceptional person.
And when you see what they have right now
feeding us the information and then you compare
to that one, Sarah adds, It's not even believable.
She was so incredible and she took abuse and
she gave it back when necessary.
But she took tremendous abuse.
And they were nasty.
Right from day one, terrible.
But there was nobody ever like her.
And now she's going to be I mean, we don't
want to talk.
There's still is an election in November.
And I cried, you know.
So she still has to win it, they say pretty
routine, but there's nothing routine in politics,
Mike.
You know, maybe those votes don't come in.
Maybe they find a couple of million votes
like they did with us.
There'll be a big dump at 302 in the morning
in the state of Arkansas.
Speaker 1: More dumps.
Speaker 2: Of votes will be found and she
will have lost by 100 votes.
Now, I mean, it's not going to happen, but
she but she still does have an election.
So we have to remember that.
But she's an incredible person.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Now, Trump is right.
It does seem like it's that the Arkansas gubernatorial
seems like it's mostly going to be a formality.
Doesn't look like a Democrat's going to take
that one.
But this is the constant undermining of confidence
in our election systems.
And there's nothing concerning happening in
Arkansas, period.
There is nothing concerning happening in Arkansas
as far as the election goes.
It's an extremely red state, and Sarah Huckabee
Sanders will probably win.
But in some other places that are slightly
less red, red but slightly less red, we've
already seen Democrats win and they immediately
say that there's fraud, there is no evidence
of fraud.
It's that we do have a unique situation where
many Americans are completely sick and tired
of these Republican nuts.
You have many Americans who are seeing Roe
v Wade, nothing done on gun safety, nothing
presented as far as policy, just attacking
Democrats, attacking liberals, on and on and
on.
And they're sick enough of it that independents
primarily.
But some Republicans are choosing to vote
for Democrats and turning out in greater numbers.
And so we've seen some relatively surprising
Democratic wins early so far.
And we will see what happens in November.
It's not even a question.
They're going to do the voter fraud routine.
Again, it's there's not even a doubt.
Sarah Palin has already done it in Alaska.
Carrie Lake did it in Arizona.
Interestingly, nobody's saying there was fraud
where Liz Cheney lost her primary in Wyoming.
Very interesting.
I wonder why that is incredible.
With years of fraud in every race, suddenly
the Wyoming primary for Liz Cheney was totally
clean.
Well, what can you do?
Must be some explanation for that.
But they're going to keep doing this.
And it's it's totally plausible.
It will, again, lead to violence at some point
in the future.
Horrible stuff.
And they do it so casually.
It's very anti-American